hello welcome back to game sports
coverage of the electronic triple 2016
I'm your host Daniel Dwyer delighted to
be joined by the creative director
Bethesda studios mr. Todd Howard Todd
hey good to see you man it's good to
finally meet yes
it's shocking that we have actually this
is our first interview it is the first
time we're Tony's met yeah I feel like
I've made dozens of videos about your
various videos I've watched many of them
right I'm worried about you sometimes
like off in the woods forming yourself
yeah it's like Survivor were like well
someone's with it someone has a camera
so exactly I'll be okay exactly you'll
be okay the camera ops there you know
he's not just on his own right it's
great I'm very lucky to live near a
bunch of really weird places because I
live in Oakland so there's woods there
and as a beach there and thankfully the
terrains of your video games also they
match up well yes they match up so we
should only do games that look like that
yes I can do one that looks like
downtown Oakland okay that would
actually really help because that's a
bit three minutes more I'll put that on
yeah yeah okay appreciate it and
Bethesda Softworks you guys last year I
mean decided to do home thing arguably
stole the show in 2015 it was ridiculous
you announced forever
yeah I mean you were now a mobile game
developer who's quite successful we are
surprisingly yeah so I guess was a
no-brainer doing another one this year
as far as a showcase um I wouldn't say
that it's always a decision in terms of
do we have enough to show you know as
far as myself and my group we felt we
had enough to put together a good video
with DLC and shelter updates in Skyrim
so you know it's a great time with III
to kind of tell our fans and everybody
else like here's here's what's coming
from from us for the next year yeah and
you've got an incredible fan base across
some multiple platforms so let's let's
talk about one and omega specifically
Skyrim a Skyrim special edition is what
you're calling it coming out on Xbox one
and PlayStation 4
I feel like this rumor has been bounding
around for a couple of years you guys
kept it under wraps pretty good as well
has this been done for a while we
started doing it we first got the Xbox
one dev kits right so our approach was
we were doing fallout 4 at the time
but it wasn't we didn't have enough data
to kind of stress the system and learn
the console so we actually poured it
over
Skyrim to it cool kind of learn the
system and then it kind of sat there
while we finished fallout 4 and as we
were wrapping up fallout 4 kind of got
in our heads like we had been playing
the Skyrim just the pork that we had
done right and it was still like oh this
is really fun we should you know we
should add a lot to it redo the graphics
and if we like it let's get it out there
to be yeah so that's what we did it does
that help you guys sort of learn new
technology is that is that like help you
pour it over that it's a good way to
jump in and just see what's working and
what's not working our games have a lot
of data yeah so as opposed to another
game where you might you just might make
a scene you know in a level the
complication for us is we need to stream
in a big world have a lot of data so
that kind of early development that's
that's how we like to handle it
yeah and you kept it under wraps as well
I mean well enough people guessed yeah
this is it whether they dreamed they
hope yeah yeah that's what before
Bethesda Commerce has always feels like
it's a wish list and it's like oh you
know you a Christmas you asked for like
six presents and you know you're going
to get two of them because you just got
your mom's not gonna fall for that one
you're wondering which ones you're going
to get that's like what every birth is a
conference now seems like yeah yeah yeah
for me anyway and let's talk a little
bit about fallout I mean first of all
the whole impetus to sort of announce it
last year and then get it out within
three or four months was that sort of a
backlash to like the sort of awful
Kotaku leaked thing that happened yeah
well is its fall I just one of those
games that has like such a fanfare you
don't need to spend two years it was
always my plan that I don't like these
long I don't like him for any game like
I hear about a game I'm like no one goes
like I wish I could wait a year yeah
never is that the response like I want
that now yeah I think there's a period
of time where people want to be excited
for a little while and so we did feel
though because it's fall out if there
was a title we could get away with it
yeah that it was the title so I think
that kind of energy last year leading up
to release like it's weird to think that
and I said you know it's only been a
year since people heard about it right
at all yeah and so I think we're gonna
you know I like it to be a show
as possible I you know right now the way
the industry works that's probably as
short as you can do it yeah to get like
we didn't tell retail or those kind of
things so but in our future stuff I'd
like it to be short as well yeah like
you said very few games you could
probably get away with doing that
fallout 4 certainly one of them and it's
always amazing seeing you know people
take these games and play such different
versions of them enjoying them for
different reasons what's the what do you
get a kick out of when you see people
playing it like do you watch twitch
streams you watch YouTube is it the
naked and gonna make an economist yeah I
get a kick out of kind of less watching
somebody play it but more the stories
they tell afterwards right I've watched
some people play it you know go on
Twitch and watch it's that's more like
an experiment to see like what they
ignore or what they what they do more or
less of you still got your buggy games
people will say it differently like they
won't talk about they'll they'll tell
about like the high action things of the
big moments but there's a lot of
downtime hmm and I think that time is
important and people don't realize it
when they talk about it later
they don't say like I just kind of
wandered for an hour and I watch the
sunset but when they play it they do
that like I do that I think that's a
very important element not just our
games but other games like taking the
geography just be there for a while so
yeah I watch a bunch as somebody who
basically holds the creative cards on a
series that I mean multiple series but
let's talking about fall that series
that you know everyone has an answer for
something short wants something I mean I
feel like with Fallout 3 there was the
whole thing like oh it's good but like
the shooting may be not as tight as we'd
like yeah and then fallout 4 comes out
it's more of a shooter than there's a
role-playing dialogue there right how do
you like I mean you can't appease
everyone right so like how do you is a
dick as the creative sort of fulcrum
managed out or what what do you think
you listen to it and I think our fans
are used to it over time that we do like
to try new things and we'll have some
successes
I think the shooting in Fallout 4 is
really good I think I think it plays
really well obviously the way we did
some dialogue stuff that didn't
as well but it was I think you know I
know the reasons we tried that to make a
nice interactive conversation but less
successful than other things in the game
so for us we take that feedback and I
think it's I think long-term you know
and so were other things we did in the
game like the choices you have at the
end we have an opportunity something
like far Harbor like okay how many ways
can it end or let's give them more
choice with my class and so it's not
just a one-off meaning four comes out
and then we forget about it yeah you
know so and then with mods and things
like that so I think it's in it's an
ongoing thing I don't just think like oh
it's this point in time and I think that
kind of feedback we get is really really
helpful and you're right that everybody
does have an opinion and I think that's
good you know I guess you know Skyrim
came out massive mods force
you know PC we ran a show on GameSpot
for three years my remod you know with
fallout 4 have you seen that same sort
of attachment rate and do you now launch
these games as like hey you know what
this isn't just like our q4 big title
this is the game we're now going to be
supporting for like two years or longer
well you know you look at Skyrim it's
still what's 5 years old still going we
don't put a timeline on it so we kind of
have our mode of the main game comes out
then we're going to support that with
DLC and then we're going to add mod
tools' and the long tail our community
it's not multiplayer so our community
becomes modding and so you ask do we
seen that with fallout 4 we're just
starting to see it because the mod stuff
really has just come out yeah and being
able to us having that in the game with
Bethesda net makes a huge difference in
who's able to see it with the console
player so I mean the Xbox stuff just
came out right now and we've just passed
20 million mod downloads ok just like
I'm like is that right that's someone
out of them and you know the ps4 stuff
is coming hmm still a lot of work to do
there with Sony but I think with fallout
4 because it's built in the game my hope
is it's more popular in Skyrim it should
be and then with Skyrim special edition
we can have those people come over to
Skyrim who have already been doing it on
the PC and people who wanted to do it
but don't have a high end PC that can
run the cool mods that they can do it on
console is there an elements of trying
to like break down technical barriers
here as well where there are people who
probably would like mods they're just
not you know adept at using their PC or
they just it's it's worth to friction
there right yeah like being able to
download them and make them run and that
was part of it just to make it easy like
I want to try that I want to try that
make it safe because a lot of times
people are like nervous like shylack
download this thing on the internet and
see what it does to my computer and so I
think they they want us to be active in
saying you know your game won't be hos
and try these out and then just just
make it easy who do you think's doing
this because I remember when I went to
Minecon years ago I suddenly had this
realization I was like oh the people are
playing this game aren't like hardcore
PC games it's like it's a much younger
crowd who do you think is installing
mods because I'm a damn massive PC gamer
and I've always modded games and and I
do do some of the mods in Skyrim and
fallout but there seems to be like it's
do you think there's a specific like
demographic or added a lot actually
all right I guess those we've been
fortunate enough where our audience has
gotten big enough generally our audience
is more hardcore gamers yeah there
there's a lot of them right so it's like
oh that hits more of a casual audience
but there's so many hardcore gamers that
if we just we make the game for
ourselves hmm
like what do we like to play it
generally finds an audience so maybe
they're like us yeah I don't I don't
know I'm giving it a lot I guess if you
don't have to give it a lot of thought
then it's there's a novel yeah yeah yeah
and when you ever get sick of making
games but fallout and sound the Elder
Scrolls I I don't think so you know
they're worlds that we love we do have
some new stuff going that we're looking
at you were guys working on three new
projects at the moment or it depends how
you add it up but there's there are some
big ones that we have we have come in
that are that are there in the vein of
what you'd expect from us but they're
also very they're very new in different
games and bigger than in many ways than
anything we've we've done so use me like
that and then I
simply think about that fallout online
like all the history of that legal
dispute it's all in the past and maybe
that's maybe there's a bright new future
for that somewhere we have I would say
we have ideas for everything like if
someone online saying I think I should
do this like you know that's what we do
at work you know that's a we do we could
do this and that's that's like how the
VR thing came up like right hey let's
try let's try VR or let's try a mobile
game there are things you wouldn't like
generally expect from us but now it's
kind of once you see it you're like oh
yeah yeah you know they have a mobile
game or you know fallout 4 and VR when
we thought about it like let's try it
out I feel like this could be let's see
how it plays then you get entry lies
like it really is bias but the perfect
game for VR for like just exploring
exploring an area love the way the
combat works the interface is already on
your wrist right just look at it and the
game has the right flow it's like I said
I was saying about people watching
people play like there's a lot of
downtime yeah so it's not this like
super intense thing all the time the
combat has a certain pace that suits VR
and so that's just something we're going
to try yeah so how will you be able to
play fallout 4 start to finish in
virtual reality yeah because I know the
demo that they showed that the was it
the Microsoft the guy afterwards no it
was one of the fewer boots they had it
was a sort of which is the red rocket
kind of area right that demo actually is
the one we have here you can go anywhere
it's okay oh we can all right you can do
whatever you want we just kicking people
off yeah yeah I want power
you know hours-long was okay you're done
but you can take that demo I fight I go
all the way down in the city and you
know fight deathclaws Batman and all
that's great
yeah do you feel like you have sort of
creative free will to do whatever now I
mean you've been how long have you been
working at the 22 years did you envisage
that like 22 years later especially when
you look at does oh oh yeah like all of
the PC gaming companies who are formed
by the wayside that Bethesda would still
be left standing
understanding so strong I take account
of one game at a time I don't you know I
don't think about our place in terms of
where will we be ten years from now and
20 years from now it's mostly what kind
of games and experiences we want to
create let's do them the best we can and
we have been very very fortunate how do
you feel about the DLC for
why for hasn't been received by everyone
so far well I think there was some
anxiety over the season pass right you
know first time we've done one we had
opportunity to do it with Skyrim and I
felt like now I don't you know there's
kind of like a potential negative there
with a season pass right this is the
first time we've done one and I mean
it's sold really really well so we're
selling more DLC than we ever have but
we wanted to do right by the people who
bought it early on for like $30 yeah to
do right by them and say look you know
we're going to give you a lot of content
and so once nuclear world comes out it's
$70 worth of content and so you know
we've done DLC from like the horse armor
we've done every type of DST that really
is there and we have found that it's all
it's all successful it's just finding
like what we feel good about what our
users feel good about and so you know we
wanted to do we knew we wanted to do a
mix of like workshop packs and then
larger adventures so nuclear world is in
the like larger adventure quest area
it's the same problem of trying to
appease so many voices that are all
probably shouting you the same yeah as
long as you give them you know I think
all of those opinions are right like
it's good to have this type of thing
it's good to have this type of thing and
so as long as we have different types
that are available I think it works out
what are you looking at
like stepping away from your own
projects what are you looking at at e3
and what's like what's tickling your
fancy in terms of what everyone else is
shown um there's some VR stuff I want to
try I think the battlefield 1 trailer
you know once you see that you're like
okay all right I gotta go play that I'm
pretty yeah they always make incredible
stuff
so and there's so much good stuff to see
here I kind of wander around I get my
hands on very few games I promise I want
to often I'm watching someone else play
it quickly and be like okay so I mean
you are you all in on VR do you think it
you know I wouldn't use the phrase all
in you know our company has done it for
a long time you know the the it software
stuff with doom years ago right of
course
and we think fallout 4 is a good match I
kind of like hold people back from like
is this the way all games will be and
like we don't need to guess right now
just like enjoy this for what it is and
we'll we'll see where it goes
can I ask you quickly about doom
actually yeah what a wonderful surprise
that was it's you know and I got to
watch that kind of happened yeah and I
love that game and it's fun being you
know since our company has grown you
asked like how we would be over 20 years
yeah one of the great things happened as
we've grown you kind of get to the other
Studios we're very similar in how we
think about games and being a Doom
fanboy and being able to play that early
and see it come along and then like the
guys at arcane like being able to I know
people have seen dishonored twice but
then like that game is amazing you know
so you know anyone do the Homer pick
what are you looking forward to
Dishonored 2 is amazing and seeing the
new prey and all the stuff that's going
on it's almost like we have a thing we
do every holidays where all the studios
come together show their stuff early to
each other and it's like our own mini
III yeah and it's it's awesome but it's
like you the first person like PC world
you've got doom doing all their crazy
arena stuff you guys are holding on to
role-playing games dishonored is
basically the new thief and then prey
kind of looks like System Shock like I
think that's all very accurate but
actually yes I was thinking of beds we
love yeah yeah and they're they're like
a bit they're old-school but new yeah I
think everything we do and so it there's
very little we do or you know the people
in a company look at and say that is
really feel like us right ends to fall
by the wayside and stuff that were we're
putting out as a company are things that
we would we would all want to buy yeah
player
yeah and loads are exciting games
enhance the Bethesda a great to see you
guys putting a Skyrim on the latest
consoles and are you what do you I do
have a busy year coming up it sounds
like you're working on a lot of things
we don't know about at the moment we're
always busy I mean it's not as it's
different busy than last year right
we're shipping fallout 4 and doing
shelter we have more things going on
this year so it becomes more of a we
have X many DLC and new projects and
mobile so it becomes more of a an issue
in making sure we focus on the right
things at the
time right but we do have more going
than we than we ever have and expanding
you know my team in particular and
that's helps us do bigger and better
things
alright presumably we'll see you back
here then at e3 2017 presumably kind of
too early to guess yeah myself yeah you
were not finished today yet either a
tired pleasure to Monsignor yeah yeah
absolutely lovely to hang out thank you
so much for watching the GameSpot stage
over the past two three hours and change
I am dropping down to the coop stage
downstairs for a little while to hang
out with Jeff cañada but come back here
Lucy James will be back for more video
games three hours of which here on the
GameSpot stage the grant